van bleet
here's barnes quick move driving
the slam dunk
vicious and quick right to the rim
ducks inside could not get it fights for
the rebound off the head of plumbling
good hustle by duarte
[Applause]
how about that pass
you got two inside passes basically
really good movement there for jason
tatum
final second to the first green
are you kidding
except from jalen green he's starting to
see the basket
two in la phoenix charlotte
during this road stretch meanwhile
here's composite finds jeffrey mobley
with the rejection
jalen suggs
on the drive against
cada bates diop the shot goes and it
will count the three-point chance for
the magic rookie scotty barnes
abdia guarding him in the sky hook
the sky hook is back the left
eight seconds to play first quarter
duarte
he knows where the clock is lets it fly
and hits again beat him up
back up make him shoot force him to
shoot
the eight made threes for jalen green
ties the eighth made
[Applause]
intriguing match up here jackson on
mobley spins mobley with the rejection
get that weak stuff out of here
sexton now where he lays the garland
mobley runs the floor evan mobley
jaylen sucks
using the screen ross
drills it out of the corner for three
goes over top of the screen and a good
job defensively by achua here's barnes
bodies flying no call barnes able
step back three and hits his third
that's a tough three two
short
tate
the outlets are green
[Applause]
picked up 3 000 nine minutes in the
first half he once again guards moran
moran tried to go behind the back to
adams adams was not expecting it out
comes mobley mobley puts it on the floor
finds alan allen fires from the foul
line jared allen now
sucks
along the baseline bouncing it and obama
that's pretty play his excellent job
jalen sucks doing a good job probing
with the dribble
69-44
raptors shooting just 29 in a turnover
barnes
driving weaving his way through kuzma
just over three to play
here's another three two
[Applause]
put it on them young man minnesota only
shot 30 from three in the preseason
jalen green on the other side counted
his first two points of his nba career
trouble staying on the floor he's missed
a hundred games to injury in his three
seasons
as here's ricky rubio meanwhile
exploding to the hole finds the trailer
and mowgli as mowgli throws it down
double overtime game sucks nice feed
and robin lopez with the finish
this new look wrapped the club here a
little triple handle up action here it's
a backpack how about that
before they had kevin durant and james
harden he averaged 21 points per game in
brooklyn
oh no he's very capable and that guy's
capable as well
you know he eat it sag back in the pick
and roll either green again
so explosive look at the first step from
jalen great zero to 60. garland under
the basket finds it open marketing
ball pop tie into the air by mobley who
kept it a live track down by akuro
mobley to the floor draws the foul puts
it up and in as he took the contact from
clark jeff in his fourth year in the nba
jaylen sucks founded by mcbride going to
take it all the way and score
on a driving left-handed shot
happened at this stage of the game
beal loses it
banton achua
barnes and the foul
he doesn't make a couple of the next
shot i would think that they'll get him
out of the game because he's a guy from
the three to point line that can make
some things play that's why you like
duarte he just makes the plight it
doesn't matter what it is sabonis is in
good position but dwarf reason
this minnesota team i think is very
capable of scoring a ton of points oh
look at that that was well executed and
then tice punched it on okogie well he
didn't he didn't pump fake that one
huge strides last season oh the final
four in the nba
we were talking about it earlier we just
can't believe how good they are i mean
you see the pieces but they didn't fit
for a while great play
[Music]
hides the three-point bottom line but
decided not to shoot now sucks does and
he knocks it down boy the celtics corner
three air ball achua underneath
williams draped all over him tough shot
doesn't go barnes cleans up on the rim
pacers by two
and knocked away by twerking
because that behind the back was weak
that's defense there by duarte who
anticipate he could see it was weak
on the defensive end
green
to tice
good pass from jalen we've seen some
nice drives and the division
not rushing using his legs
ubra who had a solid first half go for
the pass and had that knocked away good
big fella
all-star
caliber player amazing that he has
improved his three-point shot
that suggs penetrating in and drawing a
foul
comes over fred the three no and ochua
able to strip and then barnes with a
slam dunk and the raptors lead by ten
three-point range are the washington
wizards
what a terrific read
what a terrific wreath
edwards and towns have 21 at peace uh
talk about focal
points green
to wood quiets the crowd momentarily
good teammate just all the things you
want to see
rozier left that short sexton rebounds
mobley out and running finds osmond
osmic back to mobley
look out
[Applause]
wendell carter jr and williams misses
scotty barnes with a rebound he's got 11
then no look to boucher
and that's the pass again
who's short pacers have it plenty of
time five seconds
there you go
good fine he did it again
he did it again nice poise play there
rolls through the paint
good defense by tice forcing the miss
good job sliding his feet with the guard
here comes green look at that oh
snatched an angle of two oh my goodness
you'll be seeing that later
[Applause]
sexton lines up at three
oh my mowgli dunks it in
four game makes the magic fade again
mitchell robinson setting the screen
doing a nice job
[Music]
that's beautiful franz factor cutting
along the baseline
sends it to scotty he's attacking here
don gomez shot doesn't go his own
rebound printer get out of the way
scotty barnes is on the rim
there's been about you know four or five
minute stretches they've kept him on the
floor because he's coming off that
engine
you gotta let it go duarte for three you
gotta let it go you come you come around
that corner at this time of the game you
gotta let it go
another turnover what a pass ahead pass
there by green to kpj
dunked back by wood
sexton loves the mobley back in the game
touch pass to allen allen works his way
through traffic and lays it in
wagner
nothing there gives the suggs quick
swing to anthony
he drives to wagner quick pass to suggs
for the open three it's good
gianobi better spacing in the offense
will help their game grow immensely oh
ducking in underneath great look barnes
they like harold's toughness much better
than gaffer gafford is much more
athletic
but he doesn't give you much resistance
at the rim
what a terrific pass there by duarte
getty with his first
tate
to green
step back two
good two for two that's jalen green to
be in this third quarter
section picked up by right 10-footer
mobley's here evan mobley with the
offensive rebound
those quick hands knocked that one loose
and sun's a deep pull up three
he was six feet beyond the three-point
line using this because ananovi did a
great job defensively on him
scotty turns the car oh blazing speed
lays it up and through and the hall of
famer jason kidd calls a timeout yeah
because jimmy butler is a very good uh
defensive player
stop and go dwarted baseline jumper he's
got another one little sour feelings
there always here schroeder slips by
tice recovers blocks the shot
jalen green to kevin porter
we've taken only four and made one we've
got to do a little bit better there and
our defense has to tighten up on trey
young nine points first quarter just two
of 16 before that one from behind the
yard
[Applause]
jalen sucks bouncing his way to the
basket muscles it in
translates on the other end into your
offense
right because you're laying it on the
line particularly against a guy like
duncan oh
scotty
chasers look for but he's got to take
advantage of it because duncan robinson
can't guard him
he can't guard him
that was the academy sports and outdoor
super mo
foul was on horford jalen green draws
two
two really great passes from jalen green
see that's my point
i was making is that they're trying to
get it all back at once just take your
time
and a lay-in and a foul on the hogs
careening into the defender
[Music]
the extra pass to iggy
long three by jalen suggs he thrills it
harry trent jr now kicks it over to
barnes
barnes turns a corner slam dunk
right down bay street
look back door from savannah's down
towards pj tucker was there to help
things but it wasn't clear there
tough shot on the turnaround
by board
you know getting the step back i think
he'll be okay yeah he looks to be okay
boston scores the last six points here's
another three and another mate and that
was the perfect the way you play it you
funnel him right to the big man big man
makes him shoot over the top cavs get
the possession rubio across the lead
upstairs for mobile rubio
[Applause]
now look david i got to ask you
if we can we can follow up on this when
you got past six two and under i know
you i know you did the list
quickly into the front court
and scotty
backing in on doncic spins away got it
and the foul
pacers can tie it with a two
[Applause]
five on the shot club
forte for the lead
he's got 20
tremendous first half for tata the
celtics needed that oh my goodness
another one for jalen green that's
number six but the now gets his five
reserves dozier capazo
rivers at both greens to michael and
jeff buble
upstairs to mark it what a pass ross
defended by bridges
to bomba with the sucks
that's anthony with a great cut
sucks found him on the break
fred with burch burch cut off barnes
looks around
back in spin and go
slam dunk tired legs they can't get out
to shoot
duarte
[Applause]
[Music]
i want to see every mobile have an
incredible game and turn it out tonight
colin sexton with an early steal marking
it with the triple oh
that's it on time mobley's home points
right on time
with the basketball under a minute to
play in the third sons accelerates on
bridges and lays it in
had to be a foul somewhere but they
called nothing
17 assists of career best two possession
games caruso in the pay cut off turnover
gary trent jr to fred vanvleet puts it
on the deck drives on ball slips stays
with it
[Applause]
giannis last year had seven triple
doubles he had 41 double doubles
inside nice pass sabonis from dwarf
you're right
richard turns back a quarter
here's green another three another make
number seven for jalen greene he just
tied the rockets rookie record
here's george
finds zubaz zubots down the lane tested
mobley and mobley made the rejection
that is six turnovers here in the
quarter
ball winding up the duncan was denied at
the rim bomba with the loose ball
sucks
bounces it inside the windell carter jr
[Music]
and there's a turnover
nearing the five count
they'll reset still six to shoot
out of a double team duarte picks up the
loose ball
that made up a shot to get it in
taylor three gonna be number eight yes
it can
a new rockets rookie record eight made
threes for jalen green he's got 26
points
that way here in this first quarter
heartstein canard now
goes to
the ability to control the angle on
every play zoom in zoom out rotate
around the action only on the tsn app is
the tsn.ca 5g view for more info matt
chris they sacrificed tremendously
um for the league
when you think about you having to go
play in another
regardless of where it is towards them
there with the lives such a a threat to
your defense and that's why their
three-point shooting is so excellent
because rudy rolls
green splits too how about that
[Applause]
lamar stevens
colin sexton antenna for steven likes to
love who finds mobley and mobley throws
it down cut and annanovi again hooking
them up
[Music]
the cut
the denial
it's already got the momentum going in
one direction
keep them going that way with a shot
fake
duarte inside lays it in nice pass by
jeremy lamb too during this stretch
where they have rebuilt this group
around mitchell and gobert
green circles whips it back to tate
good roll and finish from tape but the
ball movement much much better
man tries to draw a foul doesn't get it
stevens wisely slows it down
mobley at the rim from rubio
bonus
guards him and it's strong take his own
rebound gets it back up and through oh
yeah
here we go we gotta have a little scotty
van in the house
this is not what we've seen in the first
games
indiana averaging 117 per game basket by
duarte
jalen green
to the rim
business decision another turnover force
that's 11.
barnes on the inside
deeper post
i love it
a double double for fred van please
stolen by tortee saw him go a little
slow behind his back and forte pick the
pocket
15 and a quarter match
under a minute remaining no look how
about that pass
scotty barnes
gary trent jr a little bit too strong
second chance of chewa
and scotty bar to the
gary trent jr talk about his vision jack
good job keeping it out of his hands
that one doesn't go about it away
controlled by trent jr he's an angry man
right there have to miss a net
[Applause]
three minutes to go 104.92
that foul was on and over the other and
so og steps in how about that knocks
down the thread